- New show intro!
(audiance clapping)
- On this episode
I answer questions in front
of hundreds of my friends.
(audiance cheering)
(rocking music)
- You ask questions
and I'll answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Do you see DRock's new opening
for he's got something really good.
There will be none of that dun dun shit
I'm just gonna go right into it.
You're just going to have to
deal with me thats why I..
- [Jimmy] My name is Jimmy
Fisher here with my twin brother
from Chicago and..
Hold on, oh, Jimmy, shut
the fuck up! Hold on.
(audiance laughing)
I didn't even start the show yet.
Are you?
- [Jimmy] I was asking a question.
But, he's got a mike?
what's going on, I'm confused as fuck.
No worries, Jimmy, my bad.
Alex, what the fuck are you doing?
- [Alex] I'm Alex, what the hell?
- [Man1] Gary, that was Mr. Moy,
- [Man2] No, it wasn't.
Zak, what the fuck?
Are we good now? Can
you get shit together?
- [Zak] It's together, what about you?
All right, not quite dick.
All right.
Here we go, that's how we roll.
- All right.
- You guys are ready?
- [Man] And in agressive mode.
Always in agressive mode.
Hello everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk.
And this is episode 100
of the #AskGaryVee Show!
(audience cheering)
- Gary, Gary, Gary, Gary, Gary, Gary!
No, no, more, more, more, more,
no just kidding, stop, stop.
Thank you. So, VaynerNation
Hundreds of your family
members have schlep
from all over the places
as a matter of fact
we're getting to the questions
I know majority of you are local
because this was definitely not
worth schleping that far for
but, some of you did
it, some of you did it.
So, I appreciate it. I appreciate
so, make sure you tell
me where you're from.
When you ask your question
please tell me who you are
we are here that too far from VaynerMedia
we're gonna do this outside in the park
was the original plan which
is why we had an open RSVP
untill somebody with the half
a brain came up to me was like
"You know you need a permit
"if you're more than a couple
of people at the park."
I'm like, fuck, okay, we scrambled
Gansevoort hooked us up, thank you so much
We're here in the roof top
of the Gansevoort Hotel
not far VaynerMedia in New York City
and really episode 100
it could have debated
a lot of different formats
but, the concept is quite simple.
My friends, my audience,
my family is here.
They're gonna ask some questions.
I'm gonna answer to them
and we're gonna go as
long and as hard as we can
so, thank you so much
please clap it after for yourselves
because you mean a lot me.
(audiance clapping and cheering)
Obviously, obviously
there are so many of you that
I know intimately, know some what
have interacted a ton on online with
and a bunch of new faces well,
that means a ton to me so
I think we should get right into the show.
So, let's do it. Are you
guys ready now back there?
- [Alex] Ready to go.
- All right, let's do it.
- [Alex] I'm starting all way in the back.
What happened to Jimmy?
Let's go with Jimmy
Jimmy got screwed, I thought
it was gonna be Jimmy
are you good?
You're good, Jimmy, all right.
All right, all right.
- Hey, how're you doing?
Gary, I wanna say thank you so much.
My name is Vlad.
I run a restaurant in Astoria, Queens
called New York Dog House.
- [Gary] Okay.
It's a trademark spot so
there's ways of growing.
I've been doing that
for three years.
Funny that, every time I reach a hurdle
I wake up and you answer it somehow.
So, I really appreciate
that you're doing that
so, every day you've
kind of helped me grow
helped our business grow
and what I'm having problem
right now is that we're growing
and each part of the restaurant
the kitchen, the floor,
the bartending crew
they become our gang, they
all love the projects so much
so every time I brought
somebody new to the group,
they start hazing them (mumbling)
- This is gonna be a funny fucking show.
There is no India in this.
go ahead, keep going.
So, you've gotta hazing
restaurant, keep going.
- [Vlad] It's starting to sound like,
"Yo guys, this is Alfredo
He is joining our crew,
teach him what you know
and let's grow, yes I wanna grow."
So, instead of helping me you know, grow
they start fucking shit up for him.
- Yep
- [Vlad] He's like "Yo, Vlad.
What's going on? They don't
like me what the fuck is going?
What am I doing wrong?"
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And you know the crew that
I have now they're really good
but I'm really good on vibes.
I'm really big on personality.
- Let me, let me jump in on right here
because Vlad, we need
more than one question
answered on the show.
- [Vlad] I told you it was
going to be long.
- You know, and I think,
I referenced this
either in a keynote or recently
or maybe in one of the shows
where I talked about one of the things
that really when I
started VaynerMedia.
I was obsessed with this issue,
because it was something
that was a huge problem
at Wine Library.
At Wine library we also grew very quickly.
Grew from like 10 to 150 people
and the biggest problem I had,
was I don't know if they haze them.
They weren't hazing them,
they were just making
their judgment immediately.
Llike literally every employee
for like two years within two days.
Everybody in the company was like
Oh, Ricky McGee sucks crap right like
like and by the way, this was
the company at Wine Library
that had no training, no on-boarding.
Like literally showed up
and you are like go, right.
And then you had, right, so?
- [Vlad] Very easy going,
but professional courtesy, respect
but you bring your own style to it.
- Vlad, the way I fixed
that at Wine Library
was I sat down, everybody individually
when I got to place, where was
not palpable to me anymore.
One by one, and I told
them right to their face.
That they, they were part of the solution
of fixing my issue.
They weren't to go be there.
And that was probably the first time,
I gave any of them negative feedback,
because we were growing,
everything was great,
they're making more money
and everything was great.
And I told them, right to their face
and then, Vlad, and
this is the tricky one,
then I fired a couple of them.
- Right in the mouth.
I feel, I kinda have to do,
even though I love what you did do.
I think you just said it,
they are not part of solution.
Vlad fire someone.
(laughter)
That's it Vlad,
Vlad no more mic.
I have got to answer some
questions. I love you, no more.
Vlad you're out, next.
Let's clap it up for Vlad.
Just fire someone Vlad, Jesus.
All right, let's keep it going.
- My name Jimmy Fisher, from New York.
I'm with twin brothers from Chicago.
- I love it.
- And our question has to do with
him and I working on a
bunch of different projects.
- That's already a problem.
- Starting a bar (mumbling)
- Go ahead.
- Have a digital agency and then do
construction consulting
- I love it!
- Our question is working with AJ,
being brothers
- [Gary] Yes.
and in a business together.
Could you speak to us as an example,
where you guys have had a overcome that
family relationship working
through business challenge.
- So, you know, with AJ I
have had a lot less problems
that I did with my dad, for
lot of different reasons
different personalities,
different parts of the equation
I was the number two
coming up in Wine Library.
I'm the number one with VaynerMedia,
I'm eleven years older than AJ
we has started eBay business
when he was nine or ten.
So we fought, you know, he
negotiated like that business
I remember starting office like 70, 30
but then one day in, he told
me it needed to be 50-50.
And so like we fought that out
and like had our
fistacuff movements then.
You know I think, I don't, you know,
the truth is
Vayner was easy because
one the big decision
that can cause a lot of problems
was addressed immediately,
which was, we made the company 50-50.
And even though, I had all
the leverage and I was in the
market and the company
was built a lot my brand.
I thought, it was important
to start the relationship
off in the right foot and
make us equal partners.
The truth is AJ has,
AJ is very self aware
in the same that I am and he
as time has gone on recognizes
you know that disproportionate
value that I bring
he really does, like he is
being perfect partner to me.
AJ is the one in our relationship
as we looking at different
business deals, the fund
and all the future things.
He was one that came
to me and said, hey bro
I think that you should
have more of the action
as we go forward and in X, Y and Z
that takes a lot of humility,
that thinks a lot of self awareness,
that thinks a lot of things and so I think
you know we had our
fistacuffs right like,
you know we had
an argument of
he was convinced that
clients would not pay us
a fourth of what
they are paying now
for a monthly retainer.
Convinced.
And obviously me winning that debate
has helped me have some equity with him.
You know, but he brings a ton of stuff
and I've referenced that
through out the 500 questions
I've answered on this show,
he's brought a lot of value to me.
He is massively mature for his age.
And a lot of ways like you know,
not only plays the straight
man in our relationship
but he just, he's also got
magic and stuff like that
as if like he's a perfect dude.
I'm super pumped he's getting
married in three weeks.
And, and my beard is upset about that.
But, at the end of the day,
you know what it's crazy.
We're now five and half,
almost six years in this
we're actually six
years into this venture.
We've really not had a blow out, blow out!
You know, we're good at
like, we're close to, like
did you guys see the basketball video?
Like, that's what we fight,
as you saw in one little clip.
Like, when we're on the
same team, we're really good
and so we have our moments,
but I'm sure the 11 year,
you know, age difference
all the circumstances, right?
The circumstances make the
pudding as I'd like to say
and so like, though I've never said
"The circumstances make the
pudding" ever before in my life.
(audience laughing)
- I've never said it.
But the circumstances have
everything to do with it
so, I don't know if our relationship
can project things to you
but I will say this,
being the bigger man,
and I've said it a bunch
in every situation it always works.
If one of you takes the
lead as being the person
when you argue that first jumps
in and says "I love you, bro"
and like "fuck this" and whatever.
Like it will force the other one
to start doing it as
well eventually over time
I can promise you that
'cause I sure did that
a shit load with my dad
and finally after 15 fucking years,
he started playing that game out.
So, I think you should consider that.
Cool. Let's clap it up for that question.
(audience claps)
- Oh, hi, how you doing, Gary?
- I'm from Edison, New
Jersey, your hometown.
- I love that, what's your name, bro?
- My name is Alex Romero.
- I love it.
- [Alex] I'm an app developer.
I'm currently working
on an app called Haptap
which is for happy hours.
- Okay.
- But the big question I have for you
is more related to billboard marketing.
Are you behind the Tom hashtag Tom Shady?
You're a fuckin' genius.
- I wish I could take credit
for that Tom Brady hazing
billboard, but I'm not.
But thank you so much for
bringing up that question
so that we were able to
talk about it here today.
I want the loudest claps for that, man,
except for the two Patriot fans here.
(audience cheering)
- Let's keep it going.
- [Jen] Gary, I'm Jen Lebowitz.
From New York originally,
but here with my team
of community managers from Philly
and my brother from New York.
- Love it.
- Thank you so much for
the show first of all,
it's awesome, we freakin' love it.
- Oh, thank you.
- So, I wanted to ask if, well
I know you hate automation.
- Yes.
- [Jen] But you get so big
to the point where you're
scaling your community so much
that it's critical to automate.
- What?
- How do you decide what and when?
- Jen, right, that's what
you said your name.
- [Jen] Yeah. Jen.
- Jen, why is it critical to automate?
- Like if you're getting
thousands of e-mails a day
of people registering
you can't manually write back.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Okay, okay, got it.
You know, there's some big guys, let me
and this is why this show is great.
Let me redefine this.
There's a big difference
between automating
your human interaction versus
automating a sign up process
or something that can and is
acceptable to be automated.
Like, for example, I think it was today
I just saw it somewhere in my stream.
Like did the President of the
United States sign up today?
Right like, like I think
you said, the tweet was
on twitter I think Barak
Obama finally signed up
and the tweet was like, "Now,
I'm finally really here."
There's a video made six years ago
that you can see where
people got mad at me
because I said that
wasn't really Barack Obama
tweeting on his behalf
and that was fucked up
because everybody was mad at
Britney Spears for like a day
for not doing it and having her manager.
And like, everybody was all about Obama
and down on Britney at the
time, it's like, fuck this,
Britney's back, baby.
So, I wanted to back up
Britney and I jumped in
and made a video, and I was like,
do you think Barack's
really doing this?
And everybody was mad at me.
So, Jen, I think what
you need to recognize
is there's plenty of circumstances
where you need to automate,
as long as you are not making
like if your automation email
when somebody is signing up is like
"Hey, Jack, this is Rick."
Really now you're getting into that level
of like trying to fake the funk,
but automation is fine in
a lot of places, not just,
I don't want people automating
their human interaction
or making pretend it's them.
You know people get pumped when
a celebrity replies to them,
that like means something to
them and when they find out
that that's like Ricky
the PM of that person
they get disappointed and
that takes equity away.
It's just not authentic.
You see what I mean.
- [Jen] Well, thank you so much.
Yeah, that's really helpful.
- Was that it?
- Yes, thank you.
- Well, no meaning, I don't
want a second question
but like, are we now aligned like,
did that clarify that conversation?
- That totally clarifies it, thank you.
Awesome, well that's tremendous.
All right, let's clap it up.
(audience applauding)
- Is this on?
- Hell, yeah, it's on.
- Hi Gary, my name is
Julian, I'm 20 years old,
I'm from Warsaw, Poland.
- I love it.
Julian, are you the one who
I was tweeting with today?
- Yes, sir.
- And so, you didn't even
know it was going on today?
- No.
- [Gary] And then we tweeted.
- Yeah.
- And then you showed up.
- Big ups to Poland, baby, yeah!
(audience cheering)
- That's the ROI of twitter, fuck-faces!
(audience laughs)
- [Julian] (mumbling)
- All right, sorry, hold
on, I can't hear shit.
Go ahead, start over, brother.
- I mean, I was already in New York.
- I know you didn't fly from
Poland 20 minutes ago, dick.
(audience laughing)
- This guy, this guy.
I get it, I get it.
- [Julian] (mumbling)
- Start over, start over!
- I have a health care company
that's focused on limiting
obesity in America
and I'm meeting with all
these VC's and they look at me
and I look like I'm 12 years old
and they're like, you know,
"What the fuck do you know?"
- [Gary] Yep.
- so, I explained the problem
they're like, oh, yeah,
that's a really good idea
like we all really like that,
but leave it to the grown ups
and I was going, you know,
fuck you and your receding hairline.
- [Gary] Dude, I'm losing
hairs watch yourself. Go ahead.
- So, how do I get like
some respect from them
and actually make and see eye to eye
you know, a little kid whose
tackling a big problem.
- [Gary] You know look, I think
I think the truth is
that's interesting to me
because I would tell you like,
I have no empathy for you
because, this is the
greatest era of all time
of kids getting disproportional respect
because we've seen technology grow
and you know, I was looking
at the 30 and 40 year olds
in this audiance
who were like that we wish we had any
we wish we were allowed to do anything
but, go grab the coffee 20 years ago
so, I promise you like, you're
getting way more respect
the fact that a VC is willing to see you
is like, way advanced
compared to where it was
five or 10 or 15 years ago?
I would say this though
and look you need to raise money, right?
Like you're not going to see them
to go see their receding hairline,
you're going cause you want their money.
- [Julian] Yes, exactly.
- I wanna align you on
some respect factor
you're going to ask somebody
for their money, right?
so, you know, we're in a place now
where money is flowing so freely
but, I would also keep
that chip on your shoulder
because that's great. I love that.
The best thing to do
and I've said this before on this show
is sell to people that are willing to buy.
To me this second I feel any indication
that somebody is not interested
you look, I'll give you a good example
if I went on a VC pitch and it
was allocated for 45 minutes.
And if you sniffed out that just like
they're out, they're like out.
I would cut the meeting short
I want that 30 minutes back, right?
So, I'll tell you that sell
to people that are interested
versus trying to get
somebody and sell it to them.
I'm never selling to anybody
but the market that attract,
I'm selling to you guys
you're attracted to this
content. I appreciate that.
I'm not trying to convince anybody else.
This is right. I'm just
gonna go out and prove it.
You know, so I would first
it sounds like you need money
I've never gone out and raised money
I just do shit, make
money, and then go back
and tell you I told you
so, right? That you know
and so, for me it's sounds
like you need dollars
but, money is easy.
Go find the people that wanna find
their "Polish Mark Zuckerberg"
take their money and go and execute
- [Julian] The thing is I've
been here for seven days
in New York so I've of kind
of had an up hill battle
but I know what you mean.
- [Gary] Yeah, get it, but like
I'm not sure what that even meant
meaning like
- [Julian] Meaning like
- going into a bar where
they only let me in
because I am 20.
- [Gary] Right.
- I already get like shut down--
- [Julian] where all the
networking events are
so, I've actually
been standing outside
of like Wall Street firms
and like hitting up the people.
- [Gary] I think your
strategy was fucked up then.
- Probably like
- [Julian] Why?
Well, I mean, there's
two ways to look at it.
I mean, your strategy is not fucked up
if you hustle to get in the
New York, right from Poland
to try to raise money
then that's awsome,
but, then I wouldn't be
whoa is me about that like,
dude I fucking work 19 hours a day
like, I've, everybody's got struggles.
- [Julian] I work 20.
- What's that?
- [Gary] Cool, I work 21.
(audience laughing)
So, here's what I think
I think that you clearly
got hustle, right?
- [Julian] Right.
- And like, I guess, let's go backwards
well let's make it a
ask the Polish kid show.
- [Julian] Okay. Bring it.
- What do you need right now?
Money?
- [Julian] Yes.
- Cool, money is I think
money is shockingly easy.
So, what I would tell
you is I would've
before I came to New
York and knock on doors
I would've use the
internet, new thing,
and I would've e-mailed
people, hit them up on Twitter
done different things to try to have
much warmer meetings in place.
How many meetings did you have
in place when you got here?
- [Julian] I've had about seven.
- So that's good.
So how did those go?
- They went well, but looked at me
like I was 20 years old
and said this is a way
too complex problem
to solve for such a young kid
we'll give the money
to someone who's older
who has more experience.
- [Gary] I disagree.
I think that's what you
want to think they thought.
- [Julian] Well, I mean
you told me and I said
you know, I'm not gonna say it.
- [Gary] By the way, I bet
you that they said that you
because a lot of people are
bad at giving critical advice
they probably just use that as an excuse.
Because, I promise you, I know
every fucking VC in the game
and they're pumped to
give a 20 year old money.
They just wanna give it to
something that they believe in.
- [Julian] Okay, cool.
- [Gary] Cool man, good luck.
- [Julian] Thanks.
(audiance clapping)
- Is something live thing?
Okay, keep go it going.
I like it, keep it going.
I mean, India is great and all,
but like the real person here I love it.
- [Tony] Hey Gary, this is Tony Ubertaccio
I'm speaking to follow
up with Jen's question
before your follow on Instagram
I'm forever indebted,
it was the coolest thing
I could've possibly asked
for so thank you.
- Thanks, man, I'm humbled.
- So, my question is Wednesday
I'll be on stage
for the first time
at a conference speaking
and your keynotes are
particularly special and unique
but do you have any
advice on how to go about?
- Yeah, getting or how about giving it?
- [Tony] Giving your first.
I think the reason my
keynotes have worked for me is
I just stuck to what, into
the way I communicate right.
I think people over think presentations.
They are stressful and
there's a lot, you know.
First of all, look, It came
natural to me. I didn't know.
Like the first talk I ever gave,
I was like thirty something
right like, wasn't like, oh,
I'm going to be public speaker.
They come natural
to me right, but I think
I think there's another real strong reason
they worked for me and that's because
I just talk about what I know.
The reason I don't need slides,
the reason I feel very comfortable
doing #AskGaryVee show
is I stay in my lane.
I'm pumped, by the way
I'm hoping today, I can answer, not sure.
Right, you know like,
you guys saw recently
with the new Facebook
integration, just I'm using that
I don't ever thought like
so, I would say you know
and it is back to the great question
from twenty year old from Poland, right?
Which is like, you just have
to, you know it's the same game
which is like stick to what you know like
I'm, the by the way that
interaction is super fun for me
because I believe he's got a shot
I think you need to focus on
the plus side not the down side
so, I think you just need
to focus on what you know
like, you got us to speak.
The problem is, a lot of
people are faking the funk
with speaking.
Right, a lot of people are I'm an expert
before ever doing anything.
And so they are, they're stuck
because they've got a like
talk about their execution, right?
And so, as long as you
stick to what your execution is
even if it's, even if
you've been billed
and billed at a higher level
than you are think you are
just stick to what you
know, walk-in with humility.
The reason I often, start my
keynotes as you've all seen with
"How many people here,
know who I am?"
I always know that 90%
of the room doesn't.
It always freaks out the
10% that does, right?
But the world is big, and
there's a lot of stuff out there.
And so, I would walk in with humility.
I would talk about what you
know and I would communicate
the way you are most
comfortable in communicating.
I'd be crippled right now,
if I had to read cue cards
because it's not comfortable to me.
I can barely read and like
that will be a problem.
Cool, man.
(audience clapping)
I'm noticing a lot of
people are not clapping.
All right.
- Hey Gary, what's going on? It's Durrell.
- Hey Durrell!
- How you doing?
- Tremendous.
- Hey, Co-founder of Stost
which is P-to-P marketplace
for storage.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I wanted to ask you about
the economy of, the sharing economy.
- Okay.
- Where do you see it going
in the next five, 10 years?
I wanna make sure,
you and I are aligned
on the sharing economy term.
Because a lot of people are
throwing it out on different ways.
Give me some examples of
companies or some executions.
- Okay, so like Uber.
Why do you, find Uber has
a share in your company
or Resy is where you about the go?
- Well, I was about to say Breathr?
- Okay, Breathr, cool.
- Basically connecting two people.
- Got it, got it!
I just want to know, where
you see that industry going?
I see it eating up everything,
So, and here is why
I think that human inefficiency
is the most interesting
biggest upside market
I also know that people pay for time.
This is the theme that
I've clearly pounded
in these 100 shows and I'm glad
beacuse it's going to happen
and people going to say.
What blows my mind
is looking at the level of income,
you need to make to
actually buy back time
and the number is low.
You know, this is not about
making 100,000 a year,
this is not making a million
year, people that are,
you know, are being very careful
about what they
spend every dollar on
are willing to get an Uber.
Are willing to, you know,
use Postmates.
or, It's really...time man,
telling you, time is an asset,
that we'll all increasingly every day,
starting to value more and more
because we're being
pounded by so much.
And because every second you live,
is one second closer to your death, right?
And I think that people
actually subconsieously understand that.
You know time becomes
more and more valuable.
I mean, it's crazy to me, you know,
I used to, you know,
I would always hear,
older people say like,
as you get older time goes
faster. Shit is real.
Half this year is gone,
what the fuck? Right like,
like it's intense and
so, I think, I think,
anything that software
connecting two individuals
where there's a supply and
demand situation at hand,
DRock, don't tell me what to do,
where there is a supply and
demand situation at hand
is always going to be interesting, right?
like there's so many interested in that.
It's brings so much value.
Save me time or do something
that I don't want to do.
Like that's the thing for me right like,
I don't want to put that, Lizzy's like,
put that picture up in
the living room, fuck no.
I've no interest, don't want to do it.
Can't do it really well,
don't want to do it.
Super pumped to open my app, handy man.
Get the fuck over here. You know so,
I think there's going to be a ton of that.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] You got it.
(audience clapping)
- [John] Hello.
- Hello.
- [John] What's up,
Gary? Over to your right.
- Good to see you, my man.
- Cheers.
- [John] Cheers.
- My name is John Henry.
I'm a serial entrepreneur now
just coming off of my first exit
and now I'm running an accelerator.
So, it kind of puts me in an odd position
cause my first company,
my success is predicated
on how well I executed
- [Gary] Yes.
- And now I was predicated on how well
my companies get to execute
by the way shout out to Shawn
I went to Vayner/RSE last week
- Awesome
- [John] got to stop by.
- Great.
- But can you give me some
advice on what to focus on
with my companies to make sure
that they go out there and kill it.
- Yeah, listen, I really
struggled with this transition
from being the entreprenaur
at Wine Library
to investing after I made the
first three good investments
Facebook, Twitter and Tumblr,
where I was really just
trying to make money
and I was like these
are the best companies.
When I then started investing
for real which is interesting
I got dumber as I started
investing for real.
The biggest thing you need to careful of
is recognizing you're
not executing it.
I made a ton of
investments based on things
that I knew would work.
I just didn't realize, oh, crap,
the jockey can screw it up.
So, you've heard me a lot
say I bet on jockeys
a lot of times, not just the horse.
You need to be careful
that these companies
aren't just great on paper with the idea
you have to believe in the entreprenaur.
It's all operations and execution.
Every idea is good in theory.
So, I think the biggest
thing you need to lookout for
is you need to be
auditing the individuals
not necessarily the idea.
- Cool.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Thanks, I really appreciate it.
- [Gary] Thanks for being here.
- Yep.
(audience applauding)
- That's a huge, huge flaw
for people that make the shift
from being operator to investor.
You're imposing yourself into the game
and I can make every business successful.
I truly believe that.
I hear ya.
- [Archana] Hi, Gary,
- [Gary] Hey!
- My name is Archana, and
I'm a relatively new follower
but I love your work, thank you so much.
- Thank you so much.
- I'm the founder of a company
called Happy Heart Kid
and it focuses on making activity kits
for teaching kids different values.
- I love it.
- And one of the things we say
is that entreprenaurs need a lot patience.
- Yes.
- And then the second
thing is that you know,
whatever it is you can
market a shit product.
- Yes!
- I just started this company
and it's relatively new.
so I'm kind of stuck
between those two positions
I actually got samples for you here.
- Thank you.
- And I was wondering if you
want to try it with Misha
cause it's perfect for her age
and I also know that you
have invested in a company
that is very similar.
- How similar?
- [Archana] Faithbox.
- Because if it's competitive
to something I've invested in
I want you out of business.
(audience laughs)
- [Archana] (mumbling)
- Got it, got it.
So, yeah, look, first
I have to text the CEO
of Misha's activities
named Lizzie Vaynerchuk
I know my role, but of course,
I'd love to check it out
I'm thrilled and thank you
and I appreciate the hustle
which is the biggest reason
I'll probably check it out.
And so is there a question there
or were you pitching your product?
- [Archana] I was actually,
I brought it here
to try and give it to you,
I know that you are going to another event
but kind of wanted to make
sure it gets to your house
so you can try it.
- Yeah, you're really getting
into very granular terms.
(audience laughs)
- (mumbling) be able to see me,
but I'm actually holding it up.
- I appreciate it, I'm sure everybody
who is watching this can see it
and so, I think, yeah, I'll
definitely get it home.
I appreciate the hustle, I love the pitch
and I'm going to the Mets game tonight
for a business meeting as some of you know
and I'll definitely get
it home, don't worry.
I'll give it to Stunwin
cause that makes me laugh.
All right, let's move on.
(audience laughs)
- Questions?
(audience applauding)
- That was a hard core pitch.
- [Man1] Yeah.
- [Woman1] She learned from the best.
- [Chad] Hey, what's up,
Gary? My name is Chad.
- She didn't jab me all that
much for that right hook, Chef.
Yeah, go ahead.
- [Chad] Paying attention?
- Always, brother.
- My name is Chad, I'm
the founder of a company
called Brick Fest Live.
We run live Lego events that attract
tens of thousands of people.
- Fucking love that
- [Chad] (mumbling)
- Yeah, that's cool.
So, our mission is inspire,
educate, and entertain
you have the next
generation of lego builders
because, you know, 'cause that's the
- Cause it's a big fuckin' industry.
- Yeah, and it wires your
brain to problem solve.
- No question.
- which is what we're all doing.
- Yeah.
- [Chad] Right.
My question is actually more
about what you do with this show
and the people that you have
around you to support it
how much of their time is spent on you
as opposed to other things.
- All their time is spent on me.
- Okay.
- The entire team that's mixed in
is all a part of brand
Gary team, all of it.
So, some of them have
worked at VaynerMedia
within VaynerMedia before
and we plucked Steve
you know, India, you know Alex
plucked out of the machine on to the team
and others have been, you
know, cold hired just for it
Zak, Andrew, DRock, Staphon for it.
- That's awesome.
'Cause we started actually
on a YouTube channel
- Yep.
- Where, you know, all
the production was us.
- Yes.
And that's how Wine Library TV
was, but with this
I have so much more
scale and as you can tell
what I'm doing is I'm
producing so much more content
off the show for Medium
and all the distributions
so, and I'm learning through these guys
as they are actually now doing it.
DRock's right over here,
Andrew is Meerkating,
India is taking photo's.
What I am learning is what does
a production company look
like for a human being?
- Right, what does it look like?
- Which I think
Fuckin' rad, you know,
and I think that there's
you gotta understand
there's, you know, as well as I am doing
there are a whole lot
more successful people,
wealthier like they are
that top 3% of celebrity
that are way grossly over
paying their PR people,
their managers, their
boy from around the way
that they are taking care
of like all that stuff
that I think creates really
interesting business model
of the future because I do believe,
and you know this every single
person is media company,
I believe that cold.
And so, not only am I producing,
not only my giving back to a
community that's been in place
and growing but I'm getting
to learn the infrastructure
of how I would scale this if
I wanted to do it for LeBron.
- Awesome. Thanks bro!
- [Gary] Cool.
- What's up?
(mumbling)
1,700 on Meerkat. Hey, Meerkat.
I love it.
Cool.
Let's keep it going.
Hey.
- Chris Green from Massachussets
- [Gary] Hey, Chris.
Congradulations 100 episodes
of #AskGaryVee.
- Thank you, man.
Shout out to DRock for that hustle video
one of the greatest
videos I have ever seen.
- Let's here it for DRock!
(audience cheering)
- You can talk about the hustle,
you just said two questions ago
you can make any company successful,
I know you believe that, we all believe it
but when you can do so
many different things
when your hustle can turn
into so many different things
with so many opportunities today 2015
how do you chose what to do
and what's your greatest opportunity
'cause to do what you are doing?
- This is the part that I'm not great at.
You know, many around me would argue
that I've done a poor job
in selecting opportunity cost
because of the earlier question
to the gal that pitched
all the stuff of you know,
I'm playing such a long, my vulnerability
and I think I said it on one
episode, but I am not sure.
My vulnerability is that I was too patient
and I left the prime years on the table
by giving back too much
by leveraging too much,
by doing non scaleable things too much
and so it's something, you
know, I turn 40 in November
and much like when I
turned 30 and freaked out
at Wine Library, and
started Wine Library TV
I think I'm forcing the narrative
'cause I think it's convenient.
But I'm definitely feeling weird.
I'd be lying if I wasn't.
I have been spending a
ton of time on you know,
I'm sure I don't really recall this,
but I actually do recall it.
I remember thinking
like all right 30 to 40
is going to be the years
where I lay down the foundation
to buy the New York Jets.
All right, and so, you know,
I've definitely been
like, you know 40 to 50,
like this is it, right?
And I'm sure when I get to 50,
I'm like this is really it.
You know, but, I'll be honest with you
I'm not sure that I am the
best guy for this answer
because the truth is I
like non-scaleable things
I love doing stuff like this.
Like you understand at some level
and I think people will
eventually figure this out
about me, and I think a lot of people here
probably do recognize it.
I disproportionally like
people which will then probably
ultimately not allow me to
maybe squeeze out every dollar
but I'm still going to
be much happier for it.
Like this show, like I'm
going to watch this show.
Wait, hold on, let me just talk to myself.
You look terrible.
(audience laughing)
- That was me talking
to my 90-year-old self.
Like these things, it's funny
when I come across somebody
tweeting out like an episode
of Wine Library TV from like
2006, like I do a ton of stuff
that on black and white don't look like
the smart opportunity cost
play, but they are the things
that make me happy as a human being
and just hustling for the cash
so that we're buying the Jets
is only one part
of the equation for me
and so I think from a business sense
I leave a lot on the table
from a life sense, I'm happy
with my allocation of my time.
I'm happy that I get together
with former employees
that I love so much, even
though everybody around me
will say "We need those 15 minutes
"for these 700 other things
that need to happen."
I don't care.
And so, I think that you know,
I think the way I judge it
is how it feels in my
stomach and my heart.
Not my brain.
(audience applauding)
- [Woman1] (mumbling)
- Chris made the Lego thing?
Dude, wow!
Wait, when are we showing that?
We're showing that tomorrow, yeah, okay.
Wait til you see this guys,
what he made was insane.
Any way do you know the other Lego dudes?
- [Man3] We will.
- Dude, you need to see what he made?
It's sick.
All right, let's move it.
- I love Legos by the way.
- Nice.
Hey, Gary, my name is Joseph Curcuru
I'm from Staten Island.
First off I want to say,
you know, props to Gary
he just brings like this
energy and this inspiration
to his speaking and that's
just like unprecedented
and I just want to thank
him from the bottom
I'm here dude, I'm right
here man, I'm right here.
Thank you man, Thank you.
I know, I know you guys.
It's very meta up in here.
First off, I spent little bit
time working on Wall Street.
in the financial industry.
And, I know that industry
is kind of like trapped
like a lot of old ways of doing things.
And, I think they'll get really hit hard
by a lot of the electronic
training, platforms.
But on the same token
I think there's a lot of room for like
one on one communications
with your FA and your broker.
and just form someone
coming from that industry
how would you apply your
- 10 minutes.
- and your teachings or
something like that in industry?
So, you know it's funny
to be watching you,
ask that question with Mitch,
I don't know if you see in front of you.
Who I thinks execute, you know literally
my answer to your questions,
go hang out with Mitch for 15 minutes
and have a coffee after this.
I think, it's super easy.
Technology is the gate way
drug to human interaction.
Period, end of story
and believe that like,
like we'll be robots eventually,
I firmly believe that.
I'm not joking. I fully believe that.
Now, it's in my, own mind I
really hope I don't see it,
because it's weird like
I think, like brain twist
like it's crazy to think that,
like I'm in the hard core robots,
like straight up, you
know like, but until then,
I think that there's
plenty of room for that.
I think the problem is there's
too many old school folks that are like,
nothing beats the hand shake
and one to one meeting.
And they don't use the technology,
it's much like the way I branded
you know Andy sitting here.
Andy does a lot of quant,
you know growth hacking like
build the audience stuff,
like I think that, I relied too much
on just branding content.
If I could do Wine
Library TV all over again
the show be 50x, the success it was,
cause I did nothing right
from a tech stand point distribution.
It was just word of mouth,
PR, it just crushed,
quality content wise, but you know,
with technology in
place, you should use it
and so I think that, of course,
there's human interaction,
of course there's content like this.
They can play in every sector.
Obviously there's legal ramifications
in that world, but all of them have
I think the more interesting question is,
I think there's far more of the reverse
to be honest with you. I
think there's far most,
more of the emerging trend of people,
that there are still in power places
that they're realize those tech.
They can scale them and bring
them to different level.
Cool.
- [Joesph] Thank you, Gary.
Yeah, you got it.
(audiance clapping)
- We really only have 10 minutes?
Well, I don't know, I
have to go to a thing.
Yes, you know, but I don't
get it. It's only 5:11.
- [DRock] (mumbling)
Oh, you want me to mingle?
(audience laughing)
- [Man] You're gonna do something after?
So I think my plan is, as you guys know.
I'm going to this meeting.
My plan is, to probably just like.
I think it would be.
May be you should start
quick hash tag like,
hash tag like here at
AskGaryVee or something
or that's fine, just do it.
Here at AskGaryVee, don't
fucking trying to change it.
that's what it is.
And I think you guys
should talk to each other.
Go somewhere. And I think, I'm gonna try,
what I'm done with business
part of my meeting.
I'm gonna try to get back into the city
and I think I'll definitely come by
and try to high five and say hello
and you know take some selfies.
And do that, because I think
I want to answer couple more questions
and I know a lot of people schlepped
and things of that nature.
So, maybe we'll keep a little
bit like, how about this,
by show hands, how many people have
to go back far away home.
Not that you're, you can't live
in New York, New Jersey,
Connecticut or Pennsylvannia
okay, cool.
Those people that raised their hands,
that haven't interacted with me a ton,
get your ass, you can get up here.
I'll try bang out a couple
of selfies and say hello
and high five
and then the rest all try
to see in life is some time.
(audience laughing)
All right, let's keep it going.
- Hey Gary, my name is Mina Salib.
Yes, sir.
Founder of Aspire.
Aspire is a productivity
community for millennials.
We're trying to get
millennials, Generation Z
to be more productive--
- Love it.
- So, I know that you work,
16, 17, 18 hours a day.
19 hours depending on
who says they work more
you work more.
- [Gary] That's right.
- So,
- 25 hours a day bitches,
- So, my question is
especially for my audience
how are you that productive?
How do you do this every single day?
- Well, I think we have
to define productive
cause it's interesting to
Garrett's question, right?
Like, you mean how am I actually
physically executing that many
I would argue that I am not
so outrageously productive.
- So, I guess the first question--
- You know what I mean?
Let's break it down.
- I guess the first
question would be
what is your definition of productivity?
Is it hustle?
Cause every time I think
about productivity,
I just think about
- [Gary] I think results.
- You know, like when I
think about productivity
I think about results, and then I think
about short term results
and long term results.
Like, I feel like the #AskGaryVee Show
was a productive venture
because I am very humbled right now
that all of you came here today
and it makes me super duper happy, right?
I can also think it's productive
because multiple companies
have now paid me instead of
going publically speaking
because I can't make every event
they've actually paid
me for a custom version
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
So, that was productive, I get
paid a lot of money for that.
That seems pretty cool, I like that.
I also think it's productive
because my next book
that comes out in February is
going to be called #AskGaryVee
and the whole thematic
around it is that
so that's going to be productive
so there's a lot of
different ways. It depends on
how one defines productivity number one.
To me, it's the output, and
so you guys heard insight
into another thing, right?
This seven person team
is giving me a blueprint
that I'm pushing against
to try to figure out
a bigger business model.
I mean, look, my marketing
activity, for Wine Library
was productive because I
grew my family business
to a big business.
It also became the output of my learnings
that became the foundation
of my "personal brand"
which became the beacon
to building the fastest
growing social digital agency ever.
Right, like so, like I'm always
I'm doing things that people feel
are not scaleable in the moment
that I find to be very scaleable
if you are willing to look at them
in five to 10 year window.
Got it?
- [Mina] Yeah.
- Was it productive for
me to take that meeting
with Chris Dessy
when he randomly e-mailed me and said
"Hey, will you take this meeting?"
And I said sure, which
then lead to a 15 minute
I'm just going to pay
forward to this kid moment
which I love to do because you never know.
Well, this time I didn't
know because it lead
to he being one of the early
employees at BuddyMedia.
Which was a company Mika Lazzaro had
and I will tell you that
lead to free office space
for VaynerMedia when we started it.
In the ocnference room at BuddyMedia
it also lead to me giving a quote
to Mike Lazzaro for BuddyMedia
where he gave me warrents to his company
which later sold for a billion
dollars to Salesforce,
so I made seven figures
on a quote to a website
so I called that productive
for that 15 minute meeting.
But, it also lead to a friendship
that has become the core
friendships for Lizzie and I
and this Saturday night
I got to spend time
with a very small group for
his oldest son's bar mitzvah
and the speech that the son gave
and the speech that Mike gave
is something that's engraved in my heart
for the rest of my life,
I'd call that productive,
but then there's a
billion 15 minute meetings
that I take where the kids a piece of shit
and nothing good happened.
So when you play it in a net net game
I think the people are over
thinking their at bats.
Right? And I think intent matters,
I think people are trying
to be too technically sound
they are not allowing for serendipity.
and serendipity is where
all the magic is my friends.
All of it.
- [Man] Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- That was deep, right?
It's some good shit.
- So, hey, Gary, do you hear me?
- I hear you, I see you.
I love the Mario shirt.
Very nice.
Staphon, you got the Mario shirt?
- [Staphon] I will get the Mario shirt.
- Okay.
(mumbling)
- I love it.
- [Davey] Should I talk?
- Yes, you should talk.
- So, Gary, my name is Davey.
I'm from the country of Georgia
and I know you love wines
so you know my country--
- Of course.
- I read about you a lot,
and what I like is that in
one of your videos you say
one is better than the zero.
- Yes.
- I love it. I love these words
and I always do this.
- I think that's one of the best videos.
Staphon, let's hear it
for Staphon on that one!
(crowd cheers)
- So, I believe in the same so.
- [Gary] Yes.
- This way I say I'm holding
the food business today
- [Gary] Okay.
- And I believe in healthy eating
so, my question is if
I target New York City
as healthy eaters and
healthy eating city
in the future it might be right.
I know I will have one or more followers.
One is still better than zero,
but should I go in this
and should I create some
social media content
in those terms
and which it should be like,
video or deals or blogging or stuff.
What do you suggest?
- I understand what you're saying.
- Let's take a step
back, hold on to the mic.
What are you actually doing?
What's the business actually you do?
'Cause that will dictate the answer.
- All right, we have a product
start up with my friends
and I'm working at a restaurant.
- Got it.
What's the product?
- So, the product is a
Georgian recipe well modernized
for the American market.
- Interesting.
- I mean, the retail market.
- Is it an actual like food?
- Yeah, it's a food.
- [Gary] It's a food.
- It's dip, you know.
- Like a humus?
- Yeah, like a hummus, but
we are much different.
- We're much better
than hummus. Fuck hummus!
Okay.
- (mumblling)
(Gary laughing)
- So, are you asking about
marketing that product?
- No, I'm asking about
social media term?
Should I go into social media
and create some social content about
healthy eating
- [Gary] No.
- No
[Davey] will it be successful?
- You should make content
about your product.
Your product
- [Davey] Yeah, of course
- well that's it, there's not of course
you just fuckin' asked me
about some fuckin' food shit in New York.
Your product, focus on making
content around your product
and around the lifestyle of that product
but not for the sake of New
York City health enthusiasts.
Right?
- [Davey] No.
- (mumbling) Your so small.
Like you can't worry
about going that abstract.
Nobody knows, there's
not a single person here
that knows what the fuck
you are talking about.
They are like Georgian Dip,
you mean Georgia like Atlanta?
No, the former fuckin'
Soviet Union fuckers.
You know, so you know what I mean?
So like, you have to understand
like nobody understands
you have to educate, it's
kind of like, you know,
I don't if this, I left Russia young,
but like when I was growing up
we ate a ton of pomegranates.
- [Davey] Yeah.
- Right?
But nobody in America ate
Pomegranates in the '80s.
Like my friends would
come over to play Legos
and they'd be like what the fuck is that?
You know, that's not an apple.
You know, like we ate pomegranates
for years, and years, and years.
Before Pom juice came and pomegranate
became like, you know a Pinkberry flavor
so like, I think that you have a lot
of educating to do.
Like I don't know what
you're talking about
and I was born in that area.
I don't know what you're talking about
so, I think that you need focus there,
you're going too abstract, and
that's a good piece of advice
for a lot of people
like way too many people
back to I said it before,
because it's just so important.
How many people here know who I am?
90% don't, people make
way too many assumptions
they think they are bigger
than they actually are
you know, and it's fine,
it makes people feel good.
But like for as much ego
and bravado as I have
24 hours, 25 I think I
can build any business
I'm always grounded in reality.
I think you need to focus
on building a story around your product.
- [Davey] Thanks so much.
- You got it, man.
(audience applauding)
- Zak.
Where's Staphon?
- [Zak] I think Staphon,
Alex has (mumbling)
- Okay, we'll come back
here after. Go ahead.
- Hey, Gary, what's going
on? My name is Tom Matzner
I'm from Queens.
I'm co-founder of a brand
of vodka called Pruv.
- Are you a Jets fan?
- I love the Jets.
- Are you telling the
truth cause that felt soft?
(audience laughing)
- No, I absolutely love the Jets.
- I need you to name
two offensive linemen.
- Two offensive linemen?
Could I talk about Wide
Receivers or Running Backs?
- No, dick.
Because "people that love a football team"
know the offensive line.
- Should I have meant to say like?
I like, I like the Jets.
- [Gary] Respect.
(audience laughing)
- It's given that you've
started your career
with Wine Library
- [Gary] Yes.
- I wanted to see where do you
see the biggest opportunity
for innovation for Wine and Spirits brand
in the market today?
- So, look, you're going into,
first of all, I like you already
because that's ballsy to go into vodka
because vodka is past it's trend
which I actually think
begins it's next opportunity.
Two, it's crowded.
Three, it's really, really
financially intensive.
You need money.
Right, so I think you know, the nice thing
is this falls perfectly aligned
to the world we live in.
Right, like you being
part of this community,
that's your only prayer.
Your only prayer is to know
what's going on Meerkat.
Your only prayer to win is
knowing what's going on Yik Yack.
Right, and all these things.
So, I think place to
innovate is in story telling
it's not about huge billboards anymore.
It's not about going to wholesalers
and giving them tons of
dollars for their sales people
to kick in the store.
It's about creating a grounds well,
but you've got to create content
and you've got create
it in relevant places.
You've got to find micro-influencers
there's a ton to be done,
but it's a tough game, man.
It's a real tough game.
- It's tough and I guess
one of the episodes
that you said kind of
clearing out the cave
- Yes.
- before (mumbling)
- [Gary] Yes.
- That's something that
we're trying to do is just go
where other brands are
not going to right now.
- 100%, there's a ton you
need to become the vodka
of like elderly Lego builders.
(audience laughs)
- Like you're gonna
have to go super niche.
- We're going more
towards like dance music
so like EDM influencers,
everybody is there dick face.
(audience laughs)
- What are you talking about?
You're finished you're out of business.
Next.
(audience laughs)
- Let's go up here.
We're going to where other people aren't.
right, like EDM.
That's it, you're out of your Mike.
- [DRock] One more?
- What do you mean by one more?
- [DRock] You gotta wrap up that's it.
- All right, cool.
This is going to be last one.
First of all, I just want to
thank everybody for being here.
- [Woman1] No..
- You all got to go.
- There might a rain delay though
- You never know it could
rain at the Mets game.
All right
- [Mergim] Hey Gary, my
name is Mergim Selimaj.
- How are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
- [Gary] Good.
- All right, I'm a personal trainer
in a recent grad here
in the upper east side
of New York city.
- [Gary] Yep.
- I have you know, lot of
internship experiance at agencies
full service marketing agencies.
I love it. I crave it.
I want to get back into it.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Now, what is a fundamental skill
that you find a lot of entry
level marketers lacking
that you feel they should
take advantage of it.
- You know it's funny, it's
not how I think about it
to be honest with you,
it's a good question
I understand where you're going with it.
I'm not worried about what you don't have
I'm more worried about what you have.
- Bet on your strengths?
- 100%.
You know like, I'm not gonna
waiver from this stuff, right?
This is what I believe in.
And so, you know, I don't know
because, it's not how I even process.
What I want to know is, you know look
your passion for craving
it might just be enough.
You know, there is a
lot of different ways.
Now the truth is, a ton
of people have passion.
So, passion and another
skill more interesting
passion and two skills
or but, remember skills come in two forms
you went and formed it or
it naturally comes to you.
Right? And so, I think
the question is looking
I would tell you that you're
looking to get back in the game
If you innuendoing to
applying to the VaynerMedia
I think what you need
to do is walk in there
with the honest truths,
that are you as a marketer
and maybe you went over
that process through
the work ethic
because it feels like
something you can control.
But, maybe it's a DNA thing,
maybe hardwork is a DNA thing
I don't know, you know
you got to go in there with the truths
spend all your time talking
about that and move forward.
Zak, as a designer
sitting in front of you
had natural speed,
qualities as a designer.
And that's why he's so great for me
because, and that's why
he's so great for me
because, he bring so much value to me
because, we're fast.
I'm exact, we need to redesign
the entire 40 page website
and I need it in an
hour, he's like "Cool".
You know, like that you know
You know, and for other people
they think that we're crazy
that it has to go through
process and triple check
and I respect that, Bowmen
that's the original, they
don't even fit, the Bowmen
- Question for you
- [Gary] I love that.
Got it (mumbling)
I love the, he's flashing
baseball cards behind.
I got it. He's totally
hacking the system. I love it.
The Jordan upper deck card
- [Man] These are all for you.
So, I think that's it.
It's not what I'm looking for
it's you going in with what you got.
- [Mergim] Okay, thank you.
- Cool, man.
Pass the mic.
- [Man] Can I grab one quick
Yes, go ahead, let's do it,
DRock's gonna be upset, go.
- So
- [Gary] Yes, sir.
- I hate being called sir, you know?
- Well I'm sorry, I'm
just being respectful.
I love you so much for
when I asked to you clap
you said go fuck yourself, Frank Thomas
so like, I appreciate
- Go fuck yourself, sir.
- Yes, I got it.
Go ahead my man, what's your name?
- Tony Cohen,
- [Gary] Tony.
from couple of miles up the block
- Awesome.
- My son, I got Michael Corleone.
I got dragged back into an industry
that I didn't want to get into.
- Okay.
- My 16 year old son is in the UK
who I'm proud to call a
drop out cause it's genetic
- I get it.
- Got into direct sales industry
and I've trained I don't know how many
thousands of thousands
of people are in it.
But they wouldn't have a family.
So, it's like the velvet glove
and a fucking hammer
in the other hand.
- Yes.
- It's a bit tougher with the son
I'm saying you know, you
going to this meeting?
I'm going for a bike ride
and while I'm being polite and nice
being a good father he's on
the other side of the world
deep down I wanna smash my
fucking head through a window.
Where's the balance there?
- You've worked with family, I never have.
- You know, though I've
worked up and kind of parallel
like I watch my two kids
now, and start projecting
this world.
I don't know, man, look
my big thing is very similar
to the same question he had
I mean, I've no interest in
imposing my will on my kids.
All I'm going to do is listen
where you have a disconnect
is if your son's curious why
it's not working out so well
or why he's not making more
or why it's not so awsome
that's the tougher conversation
when you got really like just
splash some cold water on him
because you're going bike riding
when everybody else is
going to the sales meeting.
You know, that's me but, I don't know
I don't think I'm ready
or prepared to give advice
it's about child, because
it's a different kind of love
it's a different kind of system.
I feel great about giving
advices being the child
I feel great about being the sibling.
But, for children right now, I don't know.
I can feel what I'm projecting
which is look my kids are
gonna be really well off
and I can't expect, I
can't fake environment
so, I don't expect on deep first of all.
I don't expect anybody
to be as hungry as me.
Let alone my kids who are going to be
upper eastside rich kids, right?
So, I need to I'm not sure.
I know we have to go, I know I got it.
You got it, all right?
All right, we're getting out of here.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- Thank you, everybody.
Thank you for supporting the show.
Question of the day.
(audience applauding)
- What are your feelings
that show ends today?
- No!
- You keep asking questions,
someone else is going
to have to answer them.
- This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
- So, maybe, I'll say some
words before I tape the episode.
I really, really appreciate
everybody being here.
Obviously, some of you know,
many of you probably know
shit, if you came here you definitely know
that I've done, you know, I never thought
that I would have another show.
It never even really crossed my mind.
I didn't think I'd have one
show, let alone anything else
and so, to hit this
milestone of episode of sort.
You can't move with me, DRock?
- [DRock] Where are we headed?
- To hit this milestone is a lot of fun,
I'm really glad I was able to get here
You know, the truth is and I
think a lot of you know this
like I fundamentally feed off audience
and so, I would have never gotten here
if you guys didn't care enough to watch.
Obviously, I have zero
interest in producing something
and nobody's watching that
would stop me immediately
so, you know, it's super cliche,
I always hate when people are like
"I want to thank the fans,"
and all that kind of shit
and the truth is, I only do things
for admiration and attention
cause of the way my mom
coddled me as a child so
I really, really thank you guys
for caring and watching the show.
I've really enjoyed doing it.
To me, you know Q and A is
really the most, you know,
secretly I probably started this show
because I wanted to build
a brand around Q and A
because when I speak, as many of you know
you can go to YouTube and see the spiel
I can, I mix it up
depending on the audience
but my philosophies don't
change in 40 of the 55 minutes
I mean, I'm sure for some of
you, you watch these keynotes
and if you get one or two new
thoughts in a different talk
you're like, "Yeah, there's
something different."
Like, so this was a
chance for me to produce
a lot of content on my current thoughts
you know, a funny thing
somebody just said tweeted
I saw was like, you know,
Meerkat, didn't exist
when this show started, right?
And so many people here are streaming
so I thank you, I'm humbled
I know it's the middle of the day
I know a lot of you are hustling
and executing and doing your own thing
and for you to take time to
come and support me and the show
means a lot to me and so,
I'm gonna keep it very, very basic.
I'm gonna do my intro.
We're gonna walk around,
DRock just texted me
he's like, how many
questions do you want to do?
I'm like as many as fucking possible.
(audience cheering)
- I really, I really
have nothing else to say.
Thank you so, so much.